foreign
in on sleep my perennial favorite and
the bane of my well-being depending on
the quality but last we spoke I remember
you spoke about I think it was magnesium
three and eight
epigenin and there may have been one or
two other Lucky Charms in there right
are those still the Holy Trinity for
your sleep or do you have other things
that you've added things you've
subtracted what is your current cocktail
with the understanding that as much as
people want to fix everything with
silver bullets light exposure in the
morning exercise all these are
contributors to good good quality sleep
I still use the same sleep stack so it's
magnesium three and eight
it's spelled t-h-r e-o-n-a-t
ionine and apogenin and I've added every
once in a while I'll take 900 milligrams
of myoinositol
myoinositol has a rich literature
Association name myo is in muscle why
Mayo my question yeah I must be yeah so
it's amino acid
but it can be a neurotransmitter mimetic
extensive literature on inositol for
improving insulin sensitivity there's
also something called D chiro inositol
which is important for female fertility
we can talk about that but what I've
added in the 900 milligrams myoinositol
for is I do sometimes like many people
wake up at three in the morning to use
the restroom and although there's a
simple solution to that that I just
recently learned that really works and
I'll share it in a moment catheter
it helps me fall back asleep after that
and I am tracking my sleep because I
sleep on innate sleep and that has good
sleep tracking ability what Atiya has
taught me that a lot of the wristbands
and rings for tracking sleep while they
can be quite good and are quite good
whoops and auras being the two most
popular ones
they can get movement wrong because of
movement of Limbs whereas the eight
sleep seems to really capture slow wave
sleep rapid eye movement sleep ratios
really well yeah I use both a sleep and
Aura at the moment yeah yeah so the the
myonositol it has has helped quite a bit
with that going back to sleep thing one
way to not wake up to urinate so much in
the middle of the night I learned from a
colleague is it turns out that it's not
just how much fluid you drink which
dictates whether or not you need to
urinate because that's sort of a duh
it's also how quickly you ingest that
fluid if you gulp fluid down it actually
because of the way fluid is absorbed it
actually in the kidney
the way filtration occurs in the kidney
the way it signals to the bladder is
that it makes you have to go to the
bathroom fairly urgently so if you have
your final beverage of the day sip it
don't Culp it you know
for morning hydration the opposite is
true you actually want to gulp down
quite a lot of liquid in the morning you
can absorb quite a lot of liquid in the
morning there's a I'm reading this
really nerdy review
in nature
has this wonderful review series on
circadian rhythms in the kidney your
kidney is not the same organ first thing
in the morning as it is at night this is
what circadian biologists have been
shouting for a long time every organ is
this way but you want to hydrate pretty
heavily first thing in the morning and
then over the day you can titrate off
that liquid so I'm going to ask you to
pick some favorite children here so you
got them you got the Magnesium three and
eight l-theanine
apogenin which am I understanding
correctly that is effectively chamomile
tea on steroids High concentration
chamomile extract all right got it and
then the myo inositol myoinositol all
right 900 milligrams which turns out to
be it's a big pill but turns out to be
pretty low dose for insulin sensitivity
they give and for depression they give
people up to five grams of myoinosity a
day okay but it's a mild sedative so I
don't know how people get away with that
I'll take the four of those I will
occasionally be so tiredone before my
workout yeah occasionally I'm so tired
that I'll wake up with the pills in my
hand or on the night skin so I don't
think I'm dependent on them in any way I
will just briefly say because today
we've been talking about foundational
tools kind of the foundations of let me
just slip in the question and then you
can come no no you're good yeah the
question is if you could only choose two
of those oh easy mag 3na and apogenic
okay yeah got it yeah theanine is not
going to be good for people that have
very robust dreams or nightmares because
it will increase
how Vivid your dreams are